today the Matt Walsh show the media
frantically reports that trans activists
are fleeing the country for fear of
imaginary persecution we're supposed to
be upset about this I guess though I
can't see why also flights across the
country are grounded as the FAA
experiences a catastrophic failure of
its computer systems another major win
for our historic Transportation
secretary and the Biden Administration
has come up with another thing to ban
gas stoves apparently they're killing
you your children and the planet we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the Matt Wall Street
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the daily wire doubled in size during
2022 and that fast growth is not
stopping as we head into 2023 and we are
hiring for several different roles
already if you need to hire for your
business and you want an easier way to
find qualified candidates well all you
got to do is head to ziprecruiter.com
Walsh and try it for free ZipRecruiter
uses powerful technology to find the
right candidates for your job you see a
candidate you like well you can easily
send them a personal invite so they're
more likely to apply their user friendly
dashboard makes it easy to filter review
and rate your candidates all from one
place let ZipRecruiter help you find the
best people for all your roles four out
of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day you can see for
yourself all you do is go to
ziprecruiter.com Walsh to try
ZipRecruiter for free again that's
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
at the beginning of last year I
predicted and promised that we would be
launching a full-scale war on gender
ideology and now as we said at the
beginning of 2023 we can clearly see how
effective the anti-gender ideology
Insurgency has been multiple States
across the country including here in
Tennessee are preparing to ring in the
new year with legislation Banning the
sexual mutilation and sexual
indoctrination of children soon in uh in
these states at least things like gender
transition surgeries for minors also
family friendly quote-unquote drag shows
will be a thing of the past we have
legislation dealing with both subjects
in Tennessee which I expect to pass
quite easily these laws though have set
off a new wave of panic on the left hard
to say that when they're always in a
state of panic but uh you know it's been
in increasing even more recently as the
media and trans activists a distinction
without a difference I realize Screech
about the dangers that these legislative
efforts pose here's NBC's Joe your Caba
they them by the way trying to explain
the danger of these legislation uh
listen
we are only about a week into 2023 and
across the country people are already
seeing a wave of anti-transgender
legislation making its way into State
houses across the country more than two
dozen bills looking to restrict trans
Health Care access have already been
introduced in 11 states so far this year
you see them here in Texas three
separate bills would classify gender
affirming care for minors as child abuse
and that Oklahoma bill would ban gender
affirming care for anybody anybody under
the age of 26. I want to bring in NBC
out reporter Joe yourkiva so Joe talk
about these new bills coming forward
this year who they're targeting Etc
yeah so many of these bills like you
mentioned seek to restrict or ban access
to gender affirming Health Care
completely and that includes hormone
therapy puree blockers and surgery for
anyone under 18 but some of them are
taking it up a notch this year like
Oklahoma's for example which would bar
that care for people up to 25 and would
block coverage for that care under the
state's Medicaid plan for anyone and
then we have a bill in Texas that seeks
to completely bar miners from attempting
drag performances in the state so what
we're seeing is really an escalation of
legis of uh of this legislation and
protests on drag shows that we've seen
over the last two years you describe it
as an escalation part of that is because
we saw record anti-trans legislation
last year and you know more last year
than the year before et cetera et cetera
talk about where the trend lines are
going and what this means for people in
the lgbtq plus community
yeah well advocates in Texas have told
me that they expect things to get a lot
worse before they get better and so even
if these bills don't pass they say they
still have an impact a recent National
survey for example from the Trevor
Project found that 85 percent of trans
and non-binary youth across the country
said debates on this legislation have
negatively impacted their Mental Health
well no that's not what's going on the
debates around the legislation have not
negatively affected any child's mental
health rather the things that people
like Joe your Kaiba they them are
telling children about the legislation
are negatively affecting their mental
health these gender confused and
brainwashed kids are being told that
bills which protect them from mutilation
and sterilization and exploitation and
indoctrination will somehow put their
lives at risk they are being told with a
wink and a nudge
then maybe they might even want to kill
themselves because of it the trans
propagandists because they're among the
most evil people currently walking on
the planet tried to convince children
convince them to be a phrased The Frayed
confused and suicidal
and that is indeed having an extremely
deleterious impact on their mental
health and their physical health and
their spiritual health and and their
health in every other sense of the word
but it's not just trans indoctrinated
youths who the media says are now living
in fear trans adults are feeling so
terrified and oppressed that as Vice
reports this week they are now fleeing
the country
there will soon be trans refugee camps
in places like Canada I guess until the
camps are all shut down because the
workers at the camps all end up fired
because they can't keep track of
everybody's pronouns here's Vice
reports written as Ariel willgo's a 50
year old transgender woman has been
rapidly researching ways to flee the
United States
she's from the U.S but with physical
attacks against transgender and
non-binary people on the rise and
lawmakers targeting transgender people
with increasingly Draconian legislation
that criminalizes their very existence
wilgos is afraid the national landscape
accompanied by some of her own and by
the way every time I say her or she do
the air quotes in your mind but I'm just
reading from the article this is what it
says her own personal experiences has
made a future in the U.S feel untenable
for will goes in March 2021 when wilgos
had just started her transition she was
traveling across the state for work when
she decided to stop at a public bathroom
a man followed her inside and pushed her
up against the wall
she told Vice news I thought he was
going to choke me to death
now he needs to stop here for a moment
first of all
notice how this man just began his quote
transition in 2021 and yet is already so
persecuted according to him that he
needs to leave the country
also as for the claim about the incident
in the bathroom it should be needless to
say that anytime you hear anything like
this from a trans activist actually
anytime you hear them say anything at
all about anything you should be
immediately skeptical absent any
additional evidence in this case we
aren't told whether this alleged
encounter with the man in the bathroom
even had anything to do with the fact
that Rin identifies as trans the
incident is mentioned extremely briefly
with very few details and then the story
just like moves on this is how it almost
always works with claims of anti-trans
violence very few details are provided
the story is always sketchy but you're
meant to just accept it as more proof of
an epidemic of anti-trans hate crimes
even though there is no such epidemic to
begin with but back to the story today
she feels mostly safe in Fargo North
Dakota where she lives but she's careful
in rural areas and when she leaves the
state she often doesn't feel safe at all
wilgo said there's like 30 States right
now I wouldn't even drive through her
own experiences and the increasingly
hostile National Climate Inspire will
goes to start transport a budding
non-profit that seeks to help trans
people transition navigate
bureaucratic mazes and ultimately
Finance their Journeys as they flee the
country will goes is considering
claiming asylum in Iceland a country she
visited last summer and considers more
accepting and safer than the US and she
felt like being trans was a non-issue
there so there's currently a lack of
clarity around whether it's even
possible for transgender U.S citizens to
claim Asylum elsewhere and an expert
told Vice news it's unlikely the
devolving situation in the U.S has
inspired people like will goes to try
so just to uh be clear trans activists
now want to claim Asylum
in in foreign countries okay they want
to be treated like a like a Defector
fleeing North Korea and of course the
difference and it's a very subtle
difference but the difference is that
the North Korean Asylum Seeker if he's
not given Asylum and is sent back to
North Korea will almost certainly end up
in a concentration camp where he'll be
well where he will be starved and beaten
and tortured and killed
but what will happen to Rin willgos if
he has not given asylum in Iceland
what awful unspeakable fate awaits him
back in the United States
what will happen to him well literally
nothing
not a single thing in fact as a 50 year
old man who just decided about 85
seconds ago to become a woman
none of the laws being considered or
passed in any state will have any
measurable impact on him at all
he says he's terrified to even drive
through a state like Tennessee as if we
have anti-trans checkpoints set up you
know on the highway and any trans person
we catch will be cut it off to a forced
labor camp
now that's the kind of picture they want
you to have in your your mind but it's
not actually what's happening instead
our laws when they pass
will only prevent medical professionals
from chopping the breasts off of teenage
girls or sterilizing children or
committing any similar Act
so these are laws that don't restrict
trans people at all in fact they
restrict doctors
and what doctors can do to people
because we are you know we take the
controversial apparently position that
doctors should not be able to just do
whatever they want there should be
regulations and laws in place governing
what they can do
and what they can't do one of the things
that they can't do or shouldn't be able
to do is um is permanently you know and
physically alter children before they
are possibly able to consent to such a
procedure
now if Rin is coming here to butcher
children then yes he should be worried
um otherwise perfectly safe
but he already knows that I mean they
all do
what we're seeing from trans activists
is one great pageant a performance where
they pretend to be fearing for their
lives from a threat that they have
invented
I mean in reality the far left trans
activists
poses a greater danger than he faces he
is not under threat he is a threat
he pushes for the recruitment
indoctrination and Butchery of children
he poses a clear and present danger to
tilt to children
and he does this not because it will
help the children that's not why
it's not when it rain will go sir
whoever why does he feel so strongly
about making sure that children are
castrated and sterilized
because is it because he thinks it will
actually help them no
he doesn't care about them at all
but no it's it's the more people who are
trans
the better he feels about himself
this is what trans activists do
it's the trans activists who prowl about
searching for people whose lives he can
destroy for committing the sin of
disagreeing with him
as far as that go this that goes this
week provides yet another chapter in
that Saga the post-millennial reports
this on Friday the video game Company
Limited Run games fired their Community
manager a woman named Cara Lynn after a
far left trans activist using the name
purple Tinker demanded that the company
either fire Lynn because she followed
conservative users on Twitter such as
Ian miles Chong and Libs of tick tock or
lose their support Ian miles strong
tweeted a video game company called
limited runs games fired Carolyn because
some Nut Job got offended over the fact
that she follows me and lives a tick
tock according to an observer article
from 2012 purple Tinker is a biological
male who identifies as transgender and
an activist who founded BronyCon a
convention for adult men who like to
dress up as characters from the
children's television show My Little
Pony Chong posted screenshots of purple
tinker's now deleted Twitter account
the community manager for living and Run
games is a transphobe this is what this
is the Tweet is a transphobe who follows
a veritable who's who of right-wing
transphobic creeps unless it until she
is fired from the company permanently I
am not giving them another single dime
that's what purple Tinker tweeted at the
company on January 6th at 906 A.M
now at 5 40 PM the same day on their
Twitter account limited run games
announced that Lynn had been fired and
wrote quote LRG respects all personal
opinions however we remain committed to
supporting an inclusive culture upon
investigating a situation an employee
was terminated
our goal as a company is to continue to
foster a positive and safe environment
for everyone
so did they really fire an employee
by the way within hours
so it's like almost immediately made the
decision to get rid of this person
because one creepy trans activist with a
My Little Pony fetish complained about
the account she follows on Twitter
yes that seems to be precisely what
happened
and it is the sort of power trans
activist wield in a country they pretend
to be persecuted by
and they are among the only ones who
have that kind of power
where one of them can make a complaint
about someone and say I think that
person should lose their job off with
their head they have upset me
and they get a response so you or I
could never do that
they whine about the dangers and the
marginalization they face while at the
same time using their vastly outsized
political power to professionally and
financially destroy anyone who defies
them
and if they can't succeed in that regard
they will as I've discovered docks you
threatened to murder you and your family
and they do it all while refusing to
relinquish their victim status
it's exactly the behavior you would
expect from extreme narcissists who
believe that the world exists for no
other purpose than to affirm them
so in conclusion
that's all to say if they really are
leaving the country then I guess all we
should say in response is
okay
bye
now let's get to our headlines
if you're looking to upgrade your style
this year without breaking the bank then
check out true classic tees for a
limited time only my audience can get 25
off true classic tees with code Walsh at
trueclassic.com I love my true classic
tees unlike those you know generic
brands true classic tees fit a bit
tighter around the chest and in its in
the sleeves but they leave room in the
Torso for a relaxed t-shirt feel which
means that your translation if you have
a big fat beer gut you could still look
good in a true classic tier sure T but
true classic is more than just a t-shirt
company they offer an active an entire
activewear line and they've just
released new button-down shirts as well
you can build your entire wardrobe with
true classic true classic has a 100
risk-free guarantee with a 30-day return
policy with 200 000 5 Star reviews it's
no wonder these shirts are quickly
becoming a menswear go-to get 25 off at
trueclassic.com with code Walsh today
that's 25 off with code Walsh at true
Club classic.com free shipping is
included with purchases over one hundred
dollars
first headlines from daily wire breaking
all flights across the U.S grounded as
FAA systems fail all flights across the
United States were grounded Wednesday
morning as the Federal Aviation
administration's notice to air missions
system uh failed that's no Tam I suppose
is the acronym no time May State
abnormal status of the national airspace
System including problems such as Runway
closures or general bird Hazard warnings
that's what it's supposed to do the FAA
tweeted at 6 29 a.m eastern time the FAA
is working to restore its notice to air
mission system we are performing final
validation checks and reloading the
systems now operations across the
national airspace system are affected we
will provide frequent updates as we make
progress 28 minutes later the FAA issued
an update writing cleared update number
two for all stakeholders the FAA is
still working to fully restore the
notice to air mission system following
an outage
uh while some functions are beginning to
come back online National airspace
Systems Operations remain limited and
this continued for uh several hours as
as you know every flight was grounded it
was a total mess at our airports every
flight grounded
and in fact I saw this
firsthand or I guess second hand because
my my mother-in-law as it happens is
trying to fly in to you know to to visit
right now as we speak
which maybe makes me a little bit less
upset about the problems I might have
actually sabotaged the system myself I
don't that's a theory that you might
have you never know but generally it's
been a disaster and how this happened
well Fox Business has more on that says
the U.S Federal Aviation Administration
made the heavy decision Wednesday
morning to ground all domestic flights
amid a nationwide system failure A
system that is exceptionally not up to
speed according to one Aviation expert
Kyle Bailey warned that the outage could
Cascade into cancellations and delays
for days
quote the longer this goes on there's
going to be a ripple effect throughout
the entire system unlike Regional
effects from say individual Airlines
this is the entire system the United
States affecting basically every single
aircraft departing so the longer this
goes on it's just going to Cascade into
flight delays and cancellations possibly
for days
the Nationwide failure has caused the
capacity of the faa's outdated
technology to be put under a microscope
with some critics arguing that the
system is obviously behind Fox Business
host Maria Bartiromo pointed out that
the FAA systems have not been updated
since 2015.
quote it's government technology so it's
obviously behind the private sector but
this particular system is feeding data
points from almost every single airport
in the country not just large airports
but small airports to realistically all
around the world in the airspace all
around the world so everything from a
crane in the vicinity of an airport all
the way up to say a volcanic eruption
affecting airspace it's a tremendous
amounts of data points coming into these
systems from all over the world and the
systems are layered and antiquated
they're not up to speed this again is
the aviations expert not up to speed the
speed like the private sector would be
so private sectors like say SpaceX the
FDA doesn't have analysts and Engineers
on the level
um and the capacity of the private
sector the FAA not the FDA so old
outdated systems
causing major problems uh major
catastrophe so
in the summation this is another huge
victory for our transportation
department and its secretary its
historic secretary remember the historic
when we uh when when Pete mudajig was
was given this role
as Secretary of the the uh
transportation department
but maybe it turns out
that it's not a good idea to hire a
transportation secretary based solely on
the fact that he's a gay Democrat
that's the only reason he got the job
what else let me back up for a minute
it's not just that no it's not fair
that's a that's a straw man that's not
fair I apologize for that it is it's
it's uh he was hired he was given this
position because he's a gay Democrat but
also he likes trains so that was that
was another thing too he did say that
when he was asked why he got the job he
said he's always liked trains you know
he was a Thomas the tank engine fan uh
as a child as as many of us were and so
he's got that he likes Thomas the Tank
Engine
he still has Thomas the Tank Engine bed
sheets and he's a great gay Democrat and
that's why they gave him the job
maybe that's not a good reason
to give somebody a job like this or in
fact to give them any job at all it's
not just that though
there's he got the job despite not
having any qualifications at all to
speak of that have anything to do with
transportation and his primary focus on
the job has been social justice that's
what he's worried about in fact if you
want to know why these systems are still
Antiquated and outdated and they haven't
been fixed and they haven't been updated
in years and now they're failing and
causing these cascading disastrous
effects
well if you want to know why that might
be the case
um
all you got to do is look at what Pete
bootage and the uh the Department of
Transportation have been focused on what
they've been worried about
so at the beginning of last year
um people to judge put out this big memo
you can go to transportation.gov and you
can read it for yourself if you're
interested it's their Equity action plan
uh for 2022. and this is what they're
focused on
is the summary of the equity action plan
the U.S Department of Transportation is
committed to pursuing a comprehensive
approach to advancing equity for all
in response to executive order 13985
advancing racial equity and support for
underserved communities through the
federal government this Equity action
plan highlights key actions that the US
Department of Transportation will
undertake to expand access and
opportunity to all communities while
focusing on underserved overburdened and
disadvantaged communities the actions
described here fall under four Focus
areas wealth creation power of community
interventions and expanding access now
you notice there's nothing in here about
like keeping planes in the sky so we're
not focused on that we're not focused on
air traffic control
you know how about how about a how about
an action plan to make sure that planes
can fly and they're not going to run
into each other
so they're not going to actually
accidentally you know uh run into a
flock of birds and end up in the Hudson
again how about an action plan for that
John cardillo has uh more on this Equity
action plan he posted a screenshot to
his Twitter page
um and this is more of what they're
focused on
uh
the budget requests an additional 20
million dollars above the 2020-21
enacted level for the office of the
secretary to lead uh Department of
transportation's efforts to promote
equity and inclusion
with these resources
the department of gas station would
better ensure that historic Investments
under the bipartisan infrastructure law
deliver resources and benefits equitably
including communities that have been
historically underserved and adversely
affected by persistent poverty or income
inequality
Department transportation actions
include Workforce Development
disadvantaged business Enterprise
procurement data collection reporting
public participation and assistance
measures
mitigating or negating the effects of
structural obstacles to Building Wealth
and this also is specifically about the
FAA the budget provides 15 billion
dollars in discretionary budget
Authority for the Federal Aviation
Administration to improve Aviation
safety transform the nation's Aviation
infrastructure and improve cyber
security these Investments also promote
environmental justice and climate change
mitigation by prior by by prioritizing
sustainable design and construction and
enhancing Equity through more inclusive
Contracting and Workforce Development so
Sometimes the best they can do is like
it starts okay
and so the second part of this starts
okay all right so we're gonna have
something in the budget discretionary
budget and it's going to give the FAA uh
an improved ability to focus on safety
and uh Aviation infrastructure improve
cyber security all that's good that's
what you should be doing and then the
very next sentence
it all falls apart
because then they tell us well what do
they mean by that what they mean by that
is we have to worry about environmental
justice
and you know in enhancing Equity through
more inclusive Contracting and Workforce
Development
this is uh
not what anyone needs the Department of
Transportation to do
but of course the funny thing is that as
as all this was going on and you had
people on social media that were uh just
uh uh very in in in you know ruthlessly
blaming Pete bootage for this and it was
very rude and it was just not not a nice
thing to do
and so you had Defenders of people to
judge and you had leftists and Democrats
that were saying well you can't blame
him for this this is not his fault
the exact same thing we heard the exact
same thing during the uh supply chain
crisis which was going on while Pete
bootage was taking his six months of
maternity leave or however long it was
we heard the same thing well don't be
absurd it's not his fault this is
nothing he had nothing to do with this
what do you expect him to do about this
well if that's true
like if everything I've said so far is
not valid because actually this isn't
Pete buddhism's fault and Department of
Transportation has nothing to do with
this
if that's the case
then that would only prove that we don't
need the Department of Transportation
and we don't need people to judge at all
or his job at all
that this is It's they're not doing any
if they don't have anything to do
with a problem where you know it's the
transportation department
and if they have nothing to do with a
problem where every flight in the
country is grounded
that you would think that's a major
transportation issue
and if their hands are clean
on that that just tells you that they're
not doing anything that they serve no
purpose at all
so either this is their fault or the
department shouldn't exist
or both I like to go with both it is
their fault and it shouldn't exist
partially because it is their fault
all right speaking of other things that
shouldn't exist in the government
um here's a headline from Fox News
House Republicans to vote on a bill
abolishing the IRS and eliminating the
income tax Republicans and House
Representatives will vote on a bill that
would abolish the Internal Revenue
Service eliminate the national income
tax and replace it with a national
consumption tax
Fox News digital has learned the house
will be voting on Georgia Republican
representative buddy Carters
reintroduced fair tax act that aims to
reel in the IRS and remove the national
income tax as well as other taxes and
replace them with a single consumption
tax the vote on the bill was made as
part of the deal between house Speaker
Kevin McCarthy and members of the House
Freedom caucus and was pushed forward in
his quest for the gavel last week now of
course needless to say you know
abolishing the IRS and the income tax
has zero chance of actually passing uh
it's not going to pass through the
Senate it would never be signed into law
by Joe Biden
but
it's that doesn't mean that they
shouldn't vote on it
and even if it won't pass
it still should like it's it's it's
obvious so we could talk about whether
this could ever happen
but whether it should happen look of
course it should of course we should get
rid of the IRS and the income tax
what kind of a masochist what kind of
just the submissive self-loathing
masochist would you have to be
to think that we shouldn't get rid of
the IRS and the income tax
this Abomination known as the IRS
something that by the way obviously uh
the the the people that founded this
country never had in mind they've never
had this in mind
you know of course they didn't
they famously had quite a problem with
with you know the idea of being over
taxed taxation without representation
so the idea of having this massive
bureaucracy
that that can tax us simply for living
and for earning an income and not only
that but they they you know they have
direct access to our finances and our
bank accounts and not only that but they
get to take our paychecks before we get
our hands on them
as part of the withholding system and
take the part that they want and give us
the rest
like giving us an allowance of our own
income it goes to them first and then us
this was never intended
um
this and it is it is not compatible with
like any notion of economic Liberty
Freedom it's just not compatible with
that
so clearly needs to go wait now I
actually if if I could snap my fingers
and make this law
a reality and we would have the fair tax
rather than the income tax then I would
I'd do that in a second I would snap my
fingers for that in a second but I
actually don't think you know I'm in
favor of uh of abolishing the IRS and
not replacing it with the fair tax I
think we should we should just not
replace it with anything
and the 40 percent
or so of uh of your Revenue that the IRS
generates or not generates uh takes by
force that 40 of Revenue should they
should they could just do without it
okay they would still have trillions to
work with and I think that they that
that should be enough
right
so they would have whatever would be 2
trillion rather than 4 trillion
and that should be enough you should you
should be able to run a government on a
couple trillion bucks a year that's my
that's that's my uh
radical Theory
because the fair tax the idea with the
fair tax is we're gonna
get rid of the income tax but make up
for all of that quote unquote lost
Revenue with a consumption tax which
would be a national sales tax and in
order to make up for the quote unquote
lost revenue and I have to keep putting
air quotes around lost Revenue because
it's not really lost it was never the
government's Revenue to begin with it
was never never belonged to them it's
our money
but in order to make up for what is lost
um it would have to be a significant
national sales tax
and I'm not sure exactly what with the
latest proposal what they would you know
what they're proposing the national
sales tax should be but it's something
like over 20 percentage an enormous
sales tax
again still better than what we
currently have but almost anything's
better
obviously this should this should uh
this should have it won't happen but
obviously it should and we should all
support it happening
again there's no point if you pretend to
believe in anything like economic
freedom
if you've ever
talked about that
or pretended to believe in that well
that is impossible as long as the IRS
still exists
Neil Degrassi Tyson was on a podcast uh
I'm not sure which podcast this was but
he was asked about the safety of the
vaccines and I thought that this
exchange was quite revealing so we'll
watch a little bit of this here it is
your own body your own body if you want
to get an abortion get an abortion if I
want to get the vaccine I get to choose
so you can't force if I can force you to
get an abortion you shouldn't be able to
force it because it's not about you it's
about people you interact with and
that's the social contract of public we
don't we don't even know if the vaccine
worked or not at the time yes that's
what the trials are dude that's why
these childhood are you missing data out
but but let me ask you a question are we
saying only one type of scientists are
right no we're saying that the system in
place the 16 000 that's signed up no no
the system in place to test vaccines
there's an entire system that's in place
that that with review boards and all of
it and the average that's in place now
you can say you can what you can say is
I I have a better idea than all these
review boards and all these agencies and
the CDC I have a better idea here's what
you should do and that would have made
everything better okay you can put forth
that idea but what I'm saying is
in a case where you can contaminate
someone else it's not about you it's
about the collective you're assuming
Health you're assuming you're assuming
because somebody can take the vaccine uh
won't get coveted which by the way I
don't need to play the clips for you to
see it what everybody said hey if you
get it you're not going to get if you
take the vaccine you're not going to get
a Rachel Maddow Joe Biden I can give you
Fouche I can give you and you've seen
these clips before it's not like you've
never seen it before yeah what happened
they were wrong hold on so
so
um
The Strain evolved
ah it evolved so that was great you know
he he had two minutes there fair
questions
and and the first thing to always notice
so we saw the same thing with fauci just
uh the clip of play called yesterday a
couple days ago
um as always they they get they get very
upset when you even ask questions and
you're and like
they say trust the science listen to The
Experts and then when you get one of the
alleged experts into the room
and you say okay well all right can I
you say you're the expert let's talk
about this I have some questions I would
like to get an answer to the questions
you're the person I'm supposed to be
asking right
but then when you do that they get very
upset uh they they immediately feel
attacked
and that and that right there major red
flag
you know if if just basic uh
straightforward questions
get that kind of angry and flustered
response
then that tells you the person you're
talking to at some level they know that
what they're defending is indefensible
of course this was this was what what is
a woman was all about right that was my
experience has always been my experience
talking about gender ideology sitting at
take one of that well they said well
listen to The Experts on that you're not
a scientist you're not a college
President okay well let me sit down with
one of the one of the self-proclaimed
experts and ask them some basic
questions about this thing and they get
very upset same thing here with the with
the uh
with the vaccine the most we get from
Neil Degrassi Tyson is that uh well
there were systems in place
and the thing about the systems that
were in place
is that they were in place and they were
systems what more do you need
just rattling off kind of the
bureaucracy that exists citing the
bureaucracy as as proof in itself
that whatever the bureaucracy did
was valid or good
is that what there's review boards and
there's this and there's that and
they're checking and they're that so
are you suggesting that we wouldn't
trust all of these boards and committees
they're boards and committees and they
sat and they had meetings and they
agreed on things
yeah and they could be wrong
maybe they're not wrong tell me why
they're not wrong
give me the evidence that they're not
wrong
can you do that
but the most frustrating thing and again
another thing we always hear from these
people those who want to defend not just
the vaccine but defending still
defending the government the system's
response to covid
um they're kind of uh
you know revisionist history that
they're doing now is they're saying well
uh
no one ever suggested a better option if
you if you had a better idea why didn't
you say it
what are you talking about
there were many people suggesting other
ways to approach covid there were many
proposals put on the table
but they were never even considered any
proposal that was not shut everything
down put masks on everyone and put it
and put a needle in their arm any any
proposal outside of those three things
was not considered Not only was not
considered but for a period of time
there if you you would be kicked off of
social media if you even suggested it
there were many other proposals
they shout down the other proposals the
other ideas and then a couple years
later they say well no one ever had any
other ideas
I didn't hear anybody say any anything
else
well you didn't hear them because you
were closing your ears and screaming
every time they opened their mouths
that's why you didn't hear it
well here's some more good science Ellen
DeGeneres has uh some thoughts you know
she got she her show is over now and she
kind of left in disgrace and uh now she
is I think she's looking for what's the
next stage in her career and her next
stage is uh as kind of a shaman a witch
doctor doing a rain dance so here she is
with some scientific thoughts on the
rain and the flooding issues in
California listen
foreign
Mother Nature
is
yikes
well that was a good clip for me to play
Let's
that's why I never listened to Clips
before I play them because you can't
understand anything but what she did say
at the end there the point was she said
that mother nature is angry at us as
he's standing next to this flooding
River and uh and she says mother nature
is angry at us and we need to be nicer
to Mother Nature so that she's not angry
we're Mother Nature is punishing us now
the climate change alarmists the
environmentalists have been speaking
this way about the issue for a long time
think about mother nature and we've made
her angry and she's punishing us
and I think for a while people assumed
that they were being uh this was kind of
poetic language you know they're being
metaphorical so people assumed
but
that was not a valid assumption because
they mean it quite literally this is
this is a this is religion right here
this is superstition
this is this is what we have to to wrap
our minds around
this is actually what they think
so this is like a we are going full
circle back to primitive paganism
you know we're going back to
the year 600 A.D or BC even
with this uh paganism that uh you know
the Earth gets angry at us when we
mistreat it and then it punishes us
again it's not metaphor it is is literal
that's really what they believe
foreign
here's a clip that's a little bit easier
to understand I think and I want to play
one more before we get to the comment
section Stacy Abrams was interviewed by
Drew Barrymore uh who has a I suppose a
talk show or something like that and she
recounted this story
um of uh that's probably entirely
invented but still funny and ironic in
its own right so the story about kind of
her origin story
about
um being you know
dumped and dissed by a man and how that
fueled her moving forward uh listen to
this
so when I was in college I fell in love
with a boy who was mean to me
um oh God yeah yeah you know what we've
all done that yeah well he broke up with
me and he said that I was too ambitious
and wanted too many things and I would
end up alone and lonely and so I got
really mad and then I was like fine I'm
gonna figure out all the things I'm
going to do to make him Rue the day that
he was mean to me and so I this was now
I'm old I'm 49. so I'm going to be 48
we're right next to each other so you'll
appreciate this this was before Excel
this is when it was Lotus one two three
right okay we had to go to the computer
lab because owning a computer meant that
you could buy the world right I went to
the computer lab at Spelman and I did a
spreadsheet and I laid out all the
things I was going to accomplish in all
the ways I was going to just be
fantastic and magnificent and I don't
know if he's ever going to see it but
I'm I'm doing okay I'm I'm doing okay on
my Sprite
again I don't know where to begin with
this first of all look how into it Drew
Barrymore is she is she is just she's
wrapped up in this
almost certainly made up story
that by the way if it's true I'm doing
Stacy Abrams a favor here I'm cutting
her some slack I'm gonna give her the
benefit of the doubt that she's just
making that up to give herself an
interesting story to tell it's not all
that interesting
and even making it up she can't she's I
fell in love with a boy who was uh mean
to me
Drew Barrymore oh my God mean to you oh
no
but if the story is true this is
psychotic pathetic Behavior so you you
set up a spreadsheet that you still
apparently refer to
because there was one kid
like two decades ago he didn't want to
go out with you
I mean there were a lot more than
there's a lot more than one person you
want to go out with you but it's like
this one person
and so and so you have been driven this
is what the feminists they think that
this is inspiring
so they may make up a story in which she
is driven by Spite because there was one
kid who didn't want to go out with her
did he have to go out with you
like was he not allowed to say no
no means no Stacey Abrams
but the greatest thing of all is that
apparently this guy said that you're
going to be lonely and alone
and and he was right because that's
exactly what happened usually when you
tell a story like this
I I tried I fell in love with this
person and they said that I was going to
be lonely and alone that's when you
follow up by saying and I showed him I'm
happily married I have four kids um but
that's not the case for her she's not
married she's childless
and she is most famous for losing
elections one that's all she's done
childless alone and her whole career has
just been losing things
and so I I that guy if he exists
not only right but he uh we could say we
really he dodged a bullet too so well
done to that young man
let's get to the comment section
[Applause]
Seth says Matt after your discussions
about masculinity these past few days
I'm wondering what you think about men
who go to the gym and make that their
entire personalities I agree that men
should be physically fit but are we
putting too much emphasis on it and
allowing that to become our entire
vision of what masculinity is uh
probably there's an element of that
going on it's good to go to the gym you
should you should go to the gym you
should be physically fit
um there there's there's in in some
cases there are
you do see this some places on the right
where that's like the whole ideology is
just
get physically fit
be fine be financially successful like
that's that's it that's and that's
that's you know conservatism uh so RAB
Amari wrote a uh a uh an article about
this and he called remember what he
called he called it lifestyle rightism
is what he called it and uh and I think
that's a sort of a good way of putting
it where it's you know your ideology is
contained entirely in your lifestyle
and when of course it should be about
more than that
but that is an element just it's an
element but it just can't be everything
um
all right
another comment says Matt emphasizes how
people can no longer trust medical
establishments true
and that's the problem with nutrition
slash healthy eating few doctors even
understand what a good diet is you'll
hear plant-based low fat lots of fruits
and veggies Etc I went keto years ago
lost 30 plus pounds never gained it back
point is it's not just common sense what
healthy eating entails there's massive
confusion disagreement agreed agreed
parents who feed their kids crap
processed food are guilty uh
I I would amend your statement to say
that it's eating healthy is not
complicated but it's been made
complicated
we make it seem more complicated than it
is
and part of that is because of all these
different fad diets and everything else
and you've got you have some people
doing keto you've got the people that
are like well you should only eat raw
meat that you you know you should only
eat shirtless while you're you know you
should be shirtless in a forest
eating raw meat with a machete that
should be your diet like there's that
um
all these different things making it
seem more complicated than it is but it
actually is not that complicated
I don't follow any of these fad diets I
don't even I don't like I don't even
know what gluten is okay but um I
am able to eat relatively in a
relatively healthy way I'm able to not
become morbidly obese and because it's
pretty obvious like just just don't
portion control is a big thing
okay don't eat eat until you're
satisfied but not until like everyone I
think everyone kind of knows where that
level is where you could stop eating but
a lot of times you'll continue eating
just because you're like recreational
don't don't engage in recreational
eating uh obviously don't eat eat things
with a lot of processed sugar to cut
down seriously on fast food you know all
that kind of stuff like it's all it is
actually pretty obvious make sure you're
getting plenty of fruits and vegetables
I I think it is it is pretty
self-evident
now
and that's just be a basically healthy
person
if you want to be a bodybuilder or
something like that then that's when you
gotta you know if you're a cross-country
Runner well in that case I think you can
basically whatever you want because
you're burning so many calories but you
know if you're if you're an athlete or
something then it makes sense to pay to
be to take to pay more specific
attention to your diet but I think for
most people it's just about portion
control get some fruits and vegetables
don't eat cut out the fried food cut out
the fast food
you know don't eat too many snacks
don't go to the fridge and stand at the
fridge at midnight just like gorging
yourself
which I am guilty of doing plenty but I
realize that that is an unhealthy thing
to do
uh
John Curtin says your comment
they've been they've been to medical
school so they know what they know why
people get fat I'm afraid that isn't the
case my wife is a doctor and in all her
years of medical school she studied what
you can learn from a couple hours of
Googling with regards to nutrition it's
one of the problems the medical
profession has
that's an interesting note Cameron says
I actually agree with the medical
industry actually starting to address
obesity and childhood obesity instead of
going along with the woke everybody is
beautiful and healthy Mantra however
their prescription is wrong we need to
return to the physical fitness standards
in schools of the past diet and exercise
need to be pushed hard not resorting to
surgery and drugs and children
right it they're correct to treat
obesity
has a problem
but as you point out their prescription
it's not just wrong it's like
horrifically off base and it and it's it
is a prescription
that causes more problems than it solves
that that's the issue
and and even still it's not like the
medical establishment this is part of
the the contradiction is that
yeah they're talking now about
prescribing drugs to kids for obesity
and getting surgeries and all the rest
of it but they also haven't completely
abandoned the whole body positivity
thing they can never completely abandon
them
because the medical industry is captured
by the far left that's part of the far
left religion
which means they can never give up on it
entirely
um
Mike says you're totally right about the
pit bulls just a couple weeks ago I was
attacked while delivering a pizza and I
was fortunate enough to deflect the
bites with the pizza bag otherwise I
would have been mulled owner just stood
there like a deer in the headlights
thank you for bringing it bringing
attention to this
doesn't surprise me to hear that the
owner was standing there shocked and
confused because that's the way it so
often goes now yes there are pit bulls
that are used in fighting and dog
fighting and all the rest of it where
obviously the owner knows the dog is
aggressive and dangerous that the owner
wants the dog to be aggressive they just
they're also pit bulls that are abused
just like any other animal all of that
is true but
in a great number of these attacks and
maulings that happen
you hear from the owner that they were
shocked and surprised and he was such a
good little puppy and we never had an
issue with him and he's so nice to the
kids and he's so nice it's you know that
is very often the case
which tells you that all these other pit
bull owners who say that no it's all the
owner's fault I treat my pit bull very
well and so he would never do that yeah
well that's what they all say
that's what almost all of them say
anyway
but dog is an animal at the end of the
day and something can just snap and
instincts kick in that's what happens
with animals
it's uh so although the owners are
surprised there's really no cause for
being surprised it is a vicious
um instinctive animal that is acting
like it
well another year another cartoon
rendition of my bearded infant self
emblazoned on a piece of merchandise for
your personal enjoyment you can ring in
2023 with the latest installment of my
patch program The Sweet Baby New Year
patch the New Year means a new
opportunity to collect yet another
prized possession featuring my beloved
icon and prove your level of fealty to
the gang by fastening it to your
clothing your skin even or otherwise
head over to my swag Shack at
dailywire.com shop today to get yours
also in 2022 you know we launched
Jeremy's razors as a joke but it was an
important joke now just nine months and
15 premium products later we've amassed
the largest social media following of
any brand in the category we've taken
over 10 million dollars away from
so-called Men's Grooming companies that
despise masculinity but that was just
the beginning this year we've got even
more great products and woke scorching
Endeavors in store so skip the
resolutions and Join the Revolution
together we'll upend the woke economy
and finally give conservatives return on
their value and their values are you
ready this year to actually make that
change well if you are then pick up
Jeremy's razors and their hair skin
beard and body care products today by
going to dailywire.com Walsh that's
dailywire.com Walsh
now it's time for our daily cancellation
[Music]
it often comes as a surprise to people
when I tell them that I do the majority
of the cooking in my house now do I cook
because I want to challenge gender
stereotypes or do I cook because I'm a
sexist and I believe that men make
better chefs or do I cook simply because
I enjoy it and I'm good at it theories
abound but nobody can say for sure
whatever the reason for my cooking it is
partly because I cook so much that that
I reacted with special horror and took
it personally when I read the news this
week the bite Administration wants to
confiscate my gas stove and yours
everyone's the New York Post reports
quote the by Administration is
considering a nationwide ban on gas
stoves citing the harmful pollutants
released by the appliances according to
a report the consumer product safety
commission is mulling the action after
recent studies showed emissions from the
devices can cause health and respiratory
problems this is a hidden Hazard cpsc
commissioner Richard trumka Jr told the
outlet any option is on the table
products that can't be made safe
can be banned reports by the groups by
groups including the American Chemical
Society and New York University law
schools Institute for policy Integrity
found that gas stoves which are used in
40 of U.S homes while the remainder use
various forms of electric cookers emit
pollutants like nitrogen dioxide carbon
monoxide and fine matter at levels
deemed unsafe by the Environmental
Protection Agency and the World Health
Organization
the studies also link gastos to
respiratory illness cardiovascular
problems cancer and other health
conditions more than 12 percent of
childhood asthma cases can be attributed
to gas stoves according to a report
published last month by the
international Journal of Environmental
Research and Public Health
not only that by the way but AOC who
predictably jumped on the anti-gasto
bandwagon tweeted that gas stoves along
with giving a Cancer and Asthma and
destroying the planet can also cause
brain damage
and gas stoves aren't the only
appliances on The Chopping Block States
like California New York have already
moved to ban uh gas heaters like
anything run on gas must be prohibited
apparently starting with the stoves is
what we're being told
yes people have been cooking with gas
since the 1820s
you may have grown up in houses that
only ever had gas stoves millions and
millions of people have been using gas
stoves for decade upon decade without
any issue but now suddenly it's a crisis
and people who never mentioned the
crisis before
people who never said anything about the
fact that gas stoves are giving us
tumors and destroying our brains are all
quite certain now that it is happening
and they insist that drastic action be
taken in response
none of us from gas stove households
ever noticed people being struck down
with cancer or losing their minds
because of the stove
everything seemed to be working just
fine
there didn't appear to be any issue at
all
but there is an issue it turns out a
very big issue a deadly issue people are
dying they are dying
and so we must consent to whatever
exorbitant measures the powers that be
prescribe
or not
here's why
just to summarize here's why I will not
consent to this war on gas stoves and
they will have to pry my gas stove from
my cold dead hands or warm hands as the
case may be first there is no compelling
evidence for any of the claims they are
now making what what they have are a
handful of studies funded you know
usually by activist groups speculating
that gas stoves may have some link maybe
to some health problems possibly perhaps
in theory
of course you could conduct a study
finding a theoretical link between
literally any object or food or activity
and any health problem
this is easy to do if you set out with
the intention of finding the link
second a big part of the concern is
about the supposed environmental danger
CBS News reported recently gas stoves
are contributing more to global warming
than previously thought because they
constantly leak small amounts of methane
even while they're off a new study has
found the same study also found that
home stoves can emit high levels of
nitrogen oxides raising concerns about
health and indoor air quality even when
they are not running U.S gas stoves are
putting 2.6 million tons of methane in
carbon dioxide equivalent units into the
air each year A Team of California
researchers found in a study published
Thursday in the journal Environmental
Science and Technology that's equivalent
to the annual amount of greenhouse gases
from 500 000 cars or what the US puts
into the air every three and a half
hours
yes you're not only killing your
children with the gas stove you're also
killing the polar bears and the entire
planet with it
but what is the plan here okay if we're
supposed to believe that fossil fuels
are destroying the planet
what happens when we get rid of the gas
stoves
and we convert 40 million households
over to Electric all at once
and have increased our electricity usage
by that much
electricity is largely generated by
fossil fuels also so even by the
environmentalist's own logic aren't you
simply Shifting the problem not solving
it
third Point gas stoves work they just
simply work they work far better than
electric stuff they cook more evenly and
efficiently they can be controlled more
precisely an electric stove is fine for
like heating up a can of soup or maybe
even fry maybe even frying an egg
I wouldn't try to scramble an egg on an
electric stove but you could at least
fry one maybe
but that's the extent of its abilities
most real cooking requires careful
temperature control something that isn't
possible on an electric stove
not only that but electric stoves are
harder to clean they're more expensive
to operate over the course of a year
so this is yet another example of
leftist bureaucrats wanting to take
something away that is more affordable
and more functional
and which has been working fine for
millions of people for many years
and they want to do that in favor of
something crappier and more expensive
and they do all of this based on flimsy
cherry-picked data compiled by activists
who almost always stand to profit
somehow from the change they're
advocating this is what left-wing
bureaucrats do they themselves are
inefficient and useless and so they
instinctively hate anything that is
efficient and useful
they basically want every aspect of Our
Lives to be as haphazard and
dysfunctional as the agencies they run
that's that's essentially the the goal
here
fourth
finally
as always there is the hypocrisy Factor
AOC has uh has you know she's saying now
that that gas stoves cause brain damage
and yet she has taken Instagram videos
in her kitchen where you can clearly see
the gas stove in the background
which kind of think of it may actually
lend some Credence to the theory that
gas stoves cause brain damage I mean to
explain a lot in her case anyway Jill
Biden was also photographed in her own
Kitchen in 2020 with a gas stove
and of course these people all have
gasos gas stoves are better and the
elites obviously prefer the better thing
over the inferior thing
they just don't want you to have it
you can make do with your electric stove
you pee on
besides you're supposed to be eating
bugs anyway you don't need a stove for
that
that's the attitude
which is why we must respond no I will
not eat the bugs
I will not live in the pod
I will not overcook my chicken stir-fry
on an incompetent electric stove I won't
do it
instead I will say to those who wage war
on the gas stove you are all canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign